on va parler de votre vie bien alors
qu'il est né en 1968 au ghana d'une mère
ghanéenne qui d'ailleurs est retourné
vivre à accra et les trois enfants de
trois pères différents est un jour votre
mère rencontre monsieur deux seuils les
diplomates blanc mais qui travaille pour
le ghana et contrairement à votre frère
7 vous porter le nom de votre père
adoptif
d'où le nom de marcel de seuils quand
votre père est arrivé à nantes il
arrivait do ba du ghana basés
directement de moi on est passé
directement du ghana cette ville de
nantes
alors vous avez une enfance plutôt
favoriser non par rapport aux jeunes de
banlieue puisque j'ai milité dans un
beau quartier
des bons quartiers de nantes donc c'est
vrai que pour moi je m'identifie pas
forcément mais il ya un décalage
aujourd'hui quand vous rencontrez des
gens comme anelka qui ont été vraiment
élevé dans les cités non je suis un
grand disponibles nous avons une
différence dans la proche dans le
discours aussi dans le langage aussi
quelque part mais bon on n'est pas
vraiment éloignés comme ça quand même à
vous commencé le foot à l'âge de 8 ans 1
je ne suis pas mauvais au tennis ce
qu'on dit schüttler discuter du celle
inverse
il a fini au tennis à commencer par le
foot où vous commencez par le tennis si
vous finissez dans le foot vous préférez
les sports collectifs parle c'est pour
ça que vous avez choisi le football vous
savez je ne faisais plus aux alentours
de 12 12 ans que j'ai dû choisir entre
le football et le tennis parce que
j'avais un professeur qui croyait
beaucoup en moi et bon qui m'engueuler
qui me qui m'encourageait mais qui
m'engueuler aussi est bon j'ai pas
supporté quoi j'ai dit je préfère aller
dans le collectif rigoler avec les
copains et on sera mieux couet alors
vous arrivez donc au centre de formation
de nantes où vous rencontrer didier
deschamps avec qui comment elle est
devenue très amie et à cette époque en
84 vous êtes victime d'une épreuve très
difficile qui fait un petit peu basculer
votre existence
c'est la mort de votre demi frère donc
cette qu'elle lui avait gardé le nom de
son père a donc encore hésiter votre
idéal votre frère vous vous l'aimiez
beaucoup vous adoriez quand il est joué
vous lui cirer les chaussures rester
vraiment votre votre dieu et il meurt
dans un accident de voiture et du jour
au lendemain vous changé et vous dit
babu dit finalement que vous les portez
un petit peu vous à sa place les espoirs
de votre frère c'est ça
disons que vous savez dans une famille
bon lui l'était profiter footballeur
professionnel on a tablé beaucoup sur
lui et moi j'étais jeune premier bon
j'essaie aussi de faire mes classes au
centre de formation
mais c'est vrai qu'à partir du moment où
il y en a qui disparaît vous sentez un
petit peu comme si vous avez une mission
donc l'ancien véritable et là vous savez
là à ce moment là vous savez que vous
voulez devenir footballeur pro et puis
d'une certaine façon travailler beaucoup
pour vivre un petit peu la destinée
qu'il aurait pu avoir
bon j'étais déjà dans le
le dans le circuit quand même
bon ça m'a donné un petit peu plus de
force pour pour disons pour disons
franchir les différents paliers les
différentes étapes quoi la force une
responsabilité aussi par rapport à lui
vous pensé non pas par rapport à lui par
rapport à la famille parce que c'est
vrai que bon
il fallait un petit peu ça y est on a le
sentiment qu'il fallait tenir un petit
peu la famille socialement je veux dire
le maître de réussir dans le football ça
permettait un peu de donner quelques
facilités à la fin bien sûr alors vous
jouez à nantes vous jouez à marseille le
temps de gagner la coupe d'europe des
clubs champions
et puis après il ya les affaires qui
arrivent à marseille à l'om
et là ils vous vendent j'ai toujours
trouvé ça extraordinaire dans le
football nous vendent ils vous vendent
au milan ac
quand on vous vend comme un esclave est
ce que vous êtes d'accord pas là oui bah
forcément on a toujours notre mot à dire
je veux dire on signeront signe pas un
mais là c'était trop intéressant je veux
dire milan ac après que le prestigieux
oui quand même comme ça et c'est vrai
que là vous allez vraiment vous marrez
au milan ac et non c'est super truck
meilleure époque non ouais c'est sympa
parce que j'ai trouvé un entraîneur qui
a été super intelligent avec moi il sait
qu'on pouvait penser que j'allais
planter parce que bon j'étais un des
premiers français surtout j'étais pas la
star en france à ce moment là quand on
est arrivés en italie on se posait la
question
il va se planter j'ai rencontré un
entraîneur qui va vraiment bien compris
et qui m'a fait jouer dans une position
qui était vraiment lamielle qui me
correspondait puis elle stable aussi san
siro avec les 80000 personnes qui
hurlent c'est de faire quelque chose non
c'est sympa la coupe du monde 98 donc
vous jouer tous les matches sauf les 23
dernières minutes de la finale vous est
expulsé pour avoir descendu un brésilien
cafu et vous sortez du plateau du sortie
aujourd'hui du terrain
m